- On your new album,
there's a song called, "Smiling," and
I love it so much!
Because it's not,
I know a lot of people will say,
"Oh, that's for people in the limelight."
It's not. That's for
people in any vocation,
any part of your life,
you can be having that
moment where it's like,
"I'm going through so much,
"but I guess I'll keep smiling
"since that's what everyone's expecting,
"and I'm supposed to be fine," you know?
- Especially as women too, right.
I mean, we're sort of, archetypally,
it's almost like a demand to
be that hearth overseeing,
nurturing, which is normal
for us in our bodies,
but we're also applying ourselves
in this whole yang world too.
So, for me, it's all these different
archetypes that I love being.
The teacher, the mom, the artist,
the activist, the outspoken,
you know, the channeler, all
these different archetypes,
and just the hats, you know,
I mean, I'm talking to you.
You, of all people, know the
hats of mom, and then producer.
So, just going through
all these different roles,
and because of the sensitivity,
and the empath qualities,
I'm just so much more responsible
for making sure I can take breaks,
even if it's hiding in a bathroom.
I mean, you know, carrying
ear plugs with me,
don't tell anybody. (laughs)
- No, no, no.
- I'm wearing them right now.
No, just kidding.
(both laughing)
I'm reading your lips.
- I'm actually not listening to you.
- Can't hear a word you're
saying, Kelly. (laughing)
- No, that's so true.
Literally, I've had this conversation
with someone very close to me,
and I'm like, "I'm not trying to be rude.
"Like when I pull out the ear buds,
"and like the music,
"sometimes I'm not even playing anything.
"I just want silence."
I just want a moment to where
I'm not being talked at,
or I don't feel like I'm having to engage.
'Cause I feel like just
not our jobs, all jobs,
I feel like we're a society
that is constantly-
- It's a society of onness.
Like the off,
I mean, our nervous systems
were not meant to be
in cortisol mode 24/7, and
we're actually chronic stress
in the way that we're all experiencing
is traumatic.
- Fight or flight, yeah.
- It's traumatic.
- Yeah, it's constant,
I know, I know.